ja und mit extra chili cheese soso und
extra lob an die spitze das wäre es dann
anders als danke hey was geht ab
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht es gut mir gerade nicht so weil das
problem ist ich bin mir nämlich nicht
sicher
ich habe jetzt nur die chance hier mit
dir dass du mir jetzt noch mal die frage
ist es ja gleich blöd weil gleich ist er
wieder weil die kamera ist gerade einmal
gefallen
wir hatten eigentlich eine perfekte
aufnahme und dann hat es bumm gemacht
und dann war die aufnahme irgendwie dies
unterbrochen und die kann ich jetzt ja
auch auf der kamera nicht abspielen das
heißt es kann sein dass die gelöscht
oder deswegen werde ich dir die 34
fragen die wir da eben halten jetzt noch
mal eben und die nun beantwortet sie
damit es wenigstens darin haben weil das
wäre schade wenn es nicht so wäre
wir haben eben schon oben bei mir in der
wohnung einen professionellen ersten
part gedreht in dem interview die hat
früher bei werken gearbeitet jetzt
arbeitet das programm im internet und
das ist jetzt praktisch so der zweite
part wir fahren auch die bürger gegen
das haben wir jetzt alles schon hinter
uns wir machen jetzt nur praktisch noch
mal den anfang von vorne
damit das ganze sinn ergibt werde ich
auch auf jeden fall den ersten part an
und ich bin eben mit der ersten frage
gestartet und zwar wie lange liegt ein
bürger da bis er halt weggeschmissen
wird also wohl doch besser wegkommt
könne also es gibt eine bestimmte
halbzeit die angehalten werden muss und
ich waren das war zehn minuten also bei
den burger king stehen vorne auf der
verpackung sozialen drauf und da wird
immer einen strich gemacht bevor auf die
uhr geguckt wird welche uhrzeit quasi
gerade ist ja daran der mitarbeiter
hinterher in der auffangstation erkennen
wie lange der bürger schon lied und wenn
da diesen strich quasi überschritten hat
dann wird der bürger weggeworfen
ok und da habe ich auch eben dann
gefragt wird er dann bild weggeworfen
oder kommt er zu obdachlose oder so dass
nicht mehr also der wird direkt am meer
geworfen weil wie gesagt ist eine
haltbarkeitszeit die eingehalten werden
muss und die mitarbeiter bekommen die
auch nicht generell wenn du dann mal so
bedenkt oder so bei discountern oder
sowie der immer viel weggeworfen
würdest du sagen dass wir bergen auch
viel weggeworfen wird oder ist noch im
rahmen er als ich es wird halt immer
aufgeschrieben wie viel umsatz gemacht
wird ist ja eigentlich allen vielen
jahren so und dann wird auch geguckt wie
viel nachbestellt werden muss
auch in welchem maß und deswegen wird es
auch eigentlich immer völlig
aufgebraucht und
eigentlich kaum überreste wenn was
weggeworfen wird dann entweder weil es
auch im boden gefallen ist oder die
haltezeit überschritten
die anfragen dass zugestellten
ausgestellt doch auch das blöde ist nur
wir haben hinten keine teller echt war
auch ist so ein bisschen sauer ich
sterbe hier hin
eine frage die ich habe oder die hat
doch jemand gestellt es gibt ja immer so
für diese king box oder happy meal diese
auswahl vitrine
was passiert mit den spielzeugen die da
drin sind wenn wir am ende auch
ausgegeben also was mir manchmal gemacht
haben also wo es kamen kinder und die
wollten unbedingt dieses eine spielzeug
noch haben es gab es aber so nicht mehr
und haben gehalten den kunden gefragt ob
es für die okay ist wenn die das
ausgepackt spiel zwischen haben wollen
wenn nicht dann eben nicht und wenn doch
dann haben wir denen das mit gegeben
weil jürgen defekt als auch weggeworfen
das warten schon immer auch dass ich das
mal frau werden die bürger wirklich alle
einzeln zubereitet fertig gekauft mehr
schön dann kann man hier einfach
aufgeben
die zutaten sind alle frisch und
deswegen dazu bereit ok und dann wird so
dass das leben auch gesagt einmal pro
woche ungefähr kommt eine neue lieferung
alles wird eingefroren hinten
eingelagert und dann werden die halt
zubereitet also runtergekühlt zubereitet
das gleiche auch bei chicken nuggets
oder was weiß ich komme also alles was
zitiert wird und alles was auch
willkommen das tief gefroren und halt
gemüse und alles das ist falsch und ist
es dann oft so dass halt kunden die
jetzt auch nur frische pommes kriegen
oder einen frischen berger wobei ich
halt auch öfter schon mal ein bagger
hatten da bin ich mir sicher der länger
als zehn minuten so oder halt auch
bommels den content nicht mehr essen
weil ihr also labbrig waren bestimmt
eine halbe stunde keine ahnung wie
gesagt war bei eurer filiale bestimmt so
ob das jetzt überall ist es dann die
frage kommt dann oft leute die halt
sagen ey ich will noch etwas anderes
also oft würde ich jetzt nicht sagen
bei bürgern auch eher weniger wald wie
gesagt bei uns dann ja frisch zubereitet
bei dem ich so viele kunden haben und
bei den kombis kann es sein dass selbst
wenn die frisch zubereitet wurden aber
der gast es nicht gesehen hat sich
beschwert und behauptet dass die kalt
wäre und was du eben ja auch noch gesagt
hast bevor wir jetzt gleich bei werken
stehen und was bestellen
dieser tipp an leute dass man halt
selber seinen bürger zusammen stellen
kann und da runter und drauf tun kann
was man will ohne dass es teurer wird
jetzt hast du ja auch jetzt gleicht dann
gemacht als gewinner sehen du hast auf
deinen bürger in die cala pi news und
destroyer genau also man kann also
burger king gebracht damit dass man
seinen bürgern 8 dollar nach belieben
verändern kann und zwar kannst du zum
beispiel ein land schicken bestellen und
sagen dass die da am stadtweiher die
kritik so drauf haben möchtest mit extra
tomaten und extra champagner muss nichts
dafür draufzahlen in der regel kann man
auch chili cheese bekommen ohne children
s liebe gäste leider punkt unsere
kartenzahlung nicht das war ich sieben
euro kartenzahlung geht nicht dann
hätten wir gerne eine einigung schicken
wir hätten gern behandlung schicken dazu
den vegetarischen burger
dann den ohne käse ein wunsch noch ein
robot junior genau aber ohne mario und
ohne ketchup
ja und mit extra chili cheese soße und
extra lob an die spitze
das wäre es dann hörst danke das ist gar
nicht so viel ist einfach noch nie
das war jetzt sollen herausfinden was
willst du sagen so den eindruck von hier
ist das besser als bei euch oder
schlechter mehr ist nicht drin gewesen
aber ich hab schon mal gehört dass die
umstellung wie ich aufgenommen hat weil
oft vertauschen die dann sachen bei
extrawünschen also ich glaube dass die
hier das schon ordentlich machen
beispiel wird sagen daumen nach oben
wir haben das habe ich immer okay danke
angekündigt vor allem für service habe
ich mit den leuten reden naja der heute
morgen vom pizza lieferservice meinte
auch ist kein sehr stressig sein
ich habe jetzt 73 43 cent ring gegeben
hat ja das ist einfach in die kasse
getan was passiert damit überschuss in
der kasse
keine ahnung also dafür sind wir nicht
zuständig und dann hab ich ja auch kein
trinken ist ja so müssen die
angestellten hier die flinken vier jahre
dann reinigen danach musst du macht oder
gibts ja extra eine reinigung bei und
muss müssen wir das selber machen also
es gehört einfach dazu
also ich glaube in der regel machen die
auch selber ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher aber das ist aber eine eklige
frageform essen stimmt ist das öfter mal
wobei ich dazu auch erst mal gleich was
sagen kann aber stimmt es dass öfter im
so ratten oder mäuse
durch mitten drin hast du schon mal
gesehen bei euch gar nicht weil hier ich
wohne in köln und hier in der innenstadt
in restaurants und so ich habe schon
wirklich weswegen ich da auch ich
versuche das zu meiden dort essen zu
gehen auch wenn es viele sachen gibt die
wirklich lecker schmecken aber die
gebäude da sind alle so marode weil ich
schon aus dem 18 19 jahrhundert stammen
dass die kellerräume halt so lücken
haben und dadurch halt schnell so
nagetiere reinkommen und viele haben wir
wirklich hier in der innenstadt ein
richtiges problem mit so nagetieren und
ich habe das schon zweimal gesagt wisst
ihr das hier neusel im laden rumlaufen
und dann das lustige war so die erste
hat so etwas noch nie gesehen
und dann diese das zeitgleich mit dem
chef da kamen sie der chef ja wir wissen
das aber wir können ja nichts dagegen
machen
jetzt warten wir erst mal das essen das
war jetzt schon so viele fragen so für
wen war einmal der link schicken
lecker dann haben wir hier noch grund
meinen der gitarre macht ein ganz braves
später natürlich auch gespannt auf die
eins nichts gemacht haben also die chili
cheese so wirklich ein fall drauf die zu
einer pension ist und auch drauf hier
habe ich hier gar keine so einfach klein
ketchup mayo haben wir ein team
motiviert aber diesmal woche eigentlich
normalerweise so groß wie kleine
smartphone user kann man darüber
wegschauen oder haben eigentlich aber
die gehört eigentlich auf dem normalwert
von rom haben wir bei ihm zu machen
weggelassen
das ist mir egal sag mal kannst du auch
wieder zu ihren hier ist nichts schmeckt
so ist es tut mir leid leute was geht ab
schöne grüße aus kopenhagen ich habe
gerade hier das video fertig geschnitten
damit ihr heute noch im video habt weil
ich das auf jeden fall noch hochladen
wollte heute wären nämlich sonst kein zu
kommen und irgendwie ist das ende halt
auch nicht mit drauf weil halt wie
gesagt die kamera herunter gefallen ist
und diese aufnahme war beschädigt und
deswegen muss ich jetzt hier das ende
machen also die bestellung war so super
wir hatten noch ein leckeres essen und
danke nochmal an lisa dass du
mitgebracht hast ich weiß das war jetzt
nicht das coolste video aber trotzdem
hat es halt noch gefehlt als zweiter
partner von und wir sehen uns dann
morgen 19 uhr da gibt es dann wieder ein
cooles video
obwohl hier den kanal zu aktivieren da
ist alex w und wir schlagen jetzt
hinrunde oder jung